foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show it's where America hangs out
to have a conversation about your life
specifically your money your
relationships and your work you cannot
enjoy life if those three areas of your
life aren't in alignment and there is
peace in those areas and we're here to
help you so no the number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five to jump in I'm Ken Coleman I'm
joined by my colleague Dr John deloney
we're here for you this hour and so it's
time some of you are going I've been
listening I've been watching and and I
need some guidance and we're here to
help again the number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five uh
fantastic looking live studio audience
in the lobby John
yeah it's pretty amazing they're
probably here to see Dave but you got us
guys good to see you it's okay we're
used to disappointing people it won't
FaZe us at all Let's Get to Trevor to
get the calls and the coaching started
Trevor joins us uh in Detroit Michigan
Trevor how can we help
hi so I'm in college right now and I'm
I'm here to ask you whether or not you
think I'm making the right choice to be
in college because it's about 125 000
and I'm going
um for business and I already have about
forty thousand dollars saved
okay are you a freshman sophomore where
are you at in the journey I just
finished my first year okay and you got
40 000 saved are you using that are you
essentially is that going to be whittled
down over the next couple years as you
pay as much as you can for the 125.
right now I'm just investing it and I'm
trying to decide what the right thing to
do with it is how are you paying for
school
I
so I have I have loans out right now
um just student loans and my dad is
paying the interest off on it so
um and Justin he's paying the interest
off until I'm done like I graduate so
three years from now you're gonna have
125 000 in debt
yes do not do that yeah for sure whether
college is the issue or not we'll get to
that what happened what happened after
this first year that is making you
rethink your your plan
kind of small business I'm actually
working right now but
um it's I'm only 18 years old and I have
40 000 in the bank and I think I'm on
track to have a hundred thousand by the
time I graduate what's the business
it's I do mobile car detailing and what
are you gonna make this year give us a
realistic projection
for fifteen thousand dollars this summer
all right and let me answer this have
you done it enough to where you can say
with certainty that this is something
that you want to do at least for let's
call it the next three five seven years
does it mean you're locked into that
business for the rest of your life uh
but you know you want to do it or
it has revealed to you that you want to
work for yourself and be an entrepreneur
what's the answer to that question I I
know 100 I want to
um work for myself and this that I'm
definitely willing to do this for at
least a few more years
and then come up with the next idea
correct
yes yeah I I personally I'm gonna wait
you know this is how we answer what
would I do if I were you and I'm gonna
take another step and and answer it as
if I were your dad
um if I were your dad and if I were you
uh I would be fine with you pausing the
college Journey right now
because number one you don't have the
money for it you got 40 of the 125 but
even then you don't have the money and
you have to work like crazy to pay your
way through I don't think a business
degree is going to teach you anything
that you won't learn working for
yourself and hanging out with small
business owners who maybe are in the
same industry that you're in or in a
similar type uh Journey that you're in
where they started young and they've
worked their way into it and they're
multi-millionaires and they employ 20
people 40 people 60 people whatever I
just got to tell you if I were you I
would I would not finish college and I
would and I'd get out of that loan and
I'd pay off whatever you've loaned to
this point I'd pay it off and I would go
work for myself you can always go back
to school right but in this case the
two-part question John that I always ask
people
that I think really brings it right down
to brass tacks is college specifically a
degree the only way to do what you want
to do or is it the best way and in this
case Trevor I think the answer is no
it's not the best way it's certainly not
the only way well and I just did a quick
Google search while we were talking and
the
um Michigan reconnect scholarship you
turn 25 Community College is free where
you live
okay and so there's something to be said
for you have a year of credits go work
for a full year and by the way I don't
believe you that you can't do mobile
detailing and go to college at the same
time that's not true but
you can get out and work work hard
and when I say work hard I mean work
really really hard and you've got a year
of college under your belt you got a
year of working really hard under your
belt then you can make an informed
decision right now I feel like your main
goal in life isn't starting a business
it isn't getting a career it isn't
getting a degree your main goal is
getting a hundred thousand dollars in
the bank like it's some like unicorn
that you want to capture is that am I
onto something
yeah can I just say the only reason I
can't do it year round is because I'm in
Michigan so with snow and stuff I can't
I can't work outside when it's snowing
you know no I agree with you on that and
you can't do it full time to make the
kind of money you want to make and go to
school and I think in this case choosing
to work for yourself is the better
choice so what are you going to do in
the off in the off months
I I've been I've been doordashing it's
like a delivery app and I actually make
pretty surprisingly good money okay yeah
I I agree with Ken your college isn't
for you right now yeah because your
head's other places John I want him to
keep learning yeah I'd like you to go to
a couple of entrepreneurial conferences
business conferences you know uh start
reading some books start taking people
to Coffee uh who are running small
businesses in your area and say I'm a
Young Gun and I want to learn yeah and
they'd love to take to to teach you yeah
but Trevor is your dad going to be okay
with this
he yes he he actually owns his own
business and he completely understands
and he didn't know if I was making the
right choice either but every time that
I tell him that I'm worried about the
cost he just he Compares it to my sister
he just says that he's more worried
about whether it's gonna be worth it for
her not her going to college and yeah
exactly yeah so bottom line is my point
is I just wanted to ask while we got
John here uh if there was going to be
tension and letting dad know this it
doesn't sound like there is so you know
what this is a good move my friend put
it on pause uh I would absolutely
whatever loans you've run up pay off
right now pay him off you borrowed that
money you signed your name to it with 40
Grand in the bank as a taxpayer I don't
I don't feel like I have to pay your
bill you've got the money go pay it okay
and hang on the line Trevor I'm going to
give you a copy of my book The Proximity
principle which is all about getting
around people that are doing what you
want to do so right now car detailing
that's a thing you do because you like
working for yourself I would suggest you
enjoy the output of that I think making
something look orderly look nice I think
there's something artistic there for you
something that feels efficient and
excellent I think that's great but the
proximity principle is a book you need
to read and I want you to start hanging
out with other entrepreneurs in
different fields that you're interested
in because you're very young right now
and also hang on let's also give him a
uh get clear career assessment which
will give you a detailed report on the
uniqueness of you what you do best what
you love to do and what motivates you
I'm excited John when I hear from young
people like this who are uh
well they're wired to work for
themselves and solve problems and it's
all about figuring out those problems
they most want to solve I love that he
is John deloney I'm kid Coleman
Calder calls coming up
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
welcome back America you've joined the
conversation here on the Ramsey Show
we're talking about your life
specifically your money your
relationships and your work I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague Dr
John deloney for new the show Welcome
Aboard we are going to take your money
calls today but John uh as our resident
PhD times two uh is our relationship
mental health expert and I don't have a
degree I just worked hard and got here
and I'm the work expert and so we we're
going to take on some of those calls
today and John and I do a fun little
event I say event it's a pre-evented our
Building Wealth tour where we just take
questions from the crowd and you
wouldn't believe the amount of of
synergy between people who are unhappy
at work and are dragging that home or
unhappy at home and dragging it to work
and so if you're in that position today
if you've got a a really really toxic
situation at work it's a rare
opportunity to get uh some of the
Tactical and then the the emotional
advice and the mental health advice uh
John because this is an exploding issue
yeah or if your marriage is gotten
sideways or your kids are home for the
summer and you don't know what which way
is up and that's affecting your work
life give us a call man give us a call
absolutely uh to that in the guys they
share something with me John and I'm
just going to Breeze to this we're going
to get right to the phones triple eight
eight two five five two two five uh but
we were talking during the break we just
took a call in the last segment for a
young man who's finished his freshman
year and he's asking us hey should I
continue the degree and
um and so this is an interesting list of
25 high-paying jobs that don't require a
four-year degree and both of us have
spent time with Mike Rowe recently we
talk about this stuff all the time about
all the opportunities to work uh and to
do very very well and so I'm going to
skip through a lot of these and these
are median salaries all right so when
when you hear this this is not the max
this is a median okay but when you look
at police officers and detectives one
that popped out to me number eight on
the list with a median salary of sixty
six thousand I bring this up because
there is a massive need here in this
area because we've had been through a
very volatile season uh of you know and
you have a very personal connection to
this with your father some of the work
you've done
um and and I just was curious as you
look at our society today and we see
that police officers and detectives are
number eight on this list of high-paying
jobs that don't require four-year degree
uh
what's the mindset what's the health the
mental health uh that someone would need
to survive a very tough job like police
officer and detective you have to be
driven by a sense of purpose that is far
beyond you because
here's what I know I know Dave takes
care of us very well financially
and nobody I don't have to put special
clothes on every time I leave my house
because I might get shot right I also
don't have people out protesting in
front of my business telling me they
hate me and they wish I would go away
they also
um I remember being a young kid and my
mom told me you can't be a policeman
when you grow up and I said why and she
said because every day your dad goes to
work I hug him as though it's his last
right so you have to be in this for more
it's embarrassing what we pay police
officers and it's it's as a taxpayer
it's insulting that my tax dollars don't
go to more police officers to your point
a median salary here of 66 hours it's
just it's insane to me it's insane to me
right versus versus an elevator
installer and repair is number two on
this list yeah with a median salary of
97 000. now again what we're pointing
out here is high paying jobs that don't
require a college degree but in this
case there's not a lot of job growth for
those type of roles because you got guys
that are aging out you know in that role
but the police officer detective we need
that more than ever in our society
Society that's right fascinating stuff
number one on the list and I bring this
one up because of what I read about it
number one uh job uh on this list and
this is again a list of 25 jobs that
don't require four-year degree air
traffic controller with a median salary
of 129. 129 000 uh and all you need is
an associate degree but I have also read
multiple studies about how high stress
that is I've heard it's the number one
that's the list I've read but that's
been years since I've read that but I
bring that tough job I know so I bring
that up specifically because you're here
with me today all right so whether it's
air traffic control or not let's take a
job that by the nature of it so we're
not even talking culture we're not
talking Your Leader or co-workers that
could lead to stress at work and mental
health strain we're talking just
you are on it because you got multiple
gigantic flying cans of tin with lots of
people on them that could explode with
one thing so the level of focus and
pressure is the number one thing so when
you are in a role like that because I
think there are a lot of people are
listening to watching today and they
have a by nature of the actual role
itself is high pressure which then
throws off stress
what advice do you give someone like
that as they're coming into that every
day and they are in a boiler by nature
of just showing up you have to it's the
same as if you have a car and if you
look at like NASCAR those cars they
Hammer the gas right right they Hammer
the gas
and they baby those cars off the track
as though they are made of precious
metals and so you have to when I look at
this list air traffic controller
elevator if you mess up an elevator
repair install people die yeah nuclear
technician come on yeah you know uh
dental hygienist yeah I need you right
diagnostic sonographer I mean all these
things Aerospace police officer all
these are high pressure jobs so the idea
that um you just have to if you don't
get a degree then your job is going to
be less than or no dude everybody's in
it
you have to put as much commitment in
taking care of yourself and your body
and your relationships outside of the
office as you do about the job inside
yeah so good triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the number let's go
to Sterling who joins us in Salt Lake
City Utah Sterling how can we help
hey there uh John and Ken thanks for
taking my call you bet what's up
so my wife and I are in that point of
sick and tired uh we're 86 000 in debt
and expecting our second kid and we're
pretty stressed okay congratulations on
the kid uh when's baby due
uh October 12th how old is number one
two and a half oh man yeah you don't
even know what day it is no
so very very busy all right so yes you
are familiar with our plan you've got
the 86 000 in debt you called us today
what are you most stressed about
so right now from the way that we've
been looking at our budget we're 550
dollars negative every month oh
and so just trying to make ends meet in
terms of kind of what we're doing I mean
our hat where we're house poor my take
home paid per month is 4 500. our house
is just over 2 000 a month so we bought
too much there you know debt monthly is
probably about 1100 and then everything
else is just living and getting to work
and food and what do you do for a living
man
I am in Tech cells okay so my base is 86
obviously there's more but I'm trying to
live off the base because commission
ranges
um
there came a moment when my wife and I
were house poor with a newborn
and we sold our house and moved into an
apartment and everyone around us told us
we were insane in fact worse an
apartment it was a dorm in a residence
hall they told us we were insane
and we lived there for a little over a
year and it was the greatest thing we
ever did for our marriage for my
parenting for me getting well
psychologically and for our finances
because we we didn't even put a down
payment on our house our house was uh we
owe 390 bought it about a year ago all
right what's it worth now
402.
okay what's your soul what are you in
for solar 75
uh 22-8 wow that's not yeah but here's
the deal you sell the house and all of a
sudden you take that mortgage payment
and that goes into the debt snowball you
can pay the you can pay the solar off
you're presenting it as though we can't
sell the house because of the solar
right
yeah the way it was is they said when
you sell the house you either have to
pay the whole Solar off oh I see okay to
move it so that's why I'm worried is I
don't think we have enough equity in the
house yeah to pay it off if we were to
sell it
and we have just our thousand dollar
emergency fund and that's it
um I I would do one of two things one I
would
work two and three jobs like a maniac
and save up enough money to pay that
sucker off two I would stop sitting in
your house and spinning out and call a
real estate agent and get some real
numbers and some real data number three
if you have to go down to a credit union
and get a ten thousand dollar loan to
get you out of this debacle I wouldn't
be opposed to that either yeah but you
have a math problem and you've got some
really hard decisions to make and you
got to make that happen hang on the line
Sterling I want to get you connected for
free to one of our financial coaches
that will walk you through all of your
options very expertly and they're going
to give you some real hope because there
is you're okay you guys are gonna be
okay this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
foreign
this is the Ramsey show where we help
you win in your money in your
relationships and in your work I'm Ken
Coleman Dr John deloney joins me this
hour we're taking your phone calls
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five that is triple eight eight two five
five two two five uh the smart
conference is coming back John and I
love that it's such a fun day it's our
biggest event of the Year all of us the
big crew of Ramsey personalities led by
the the the chief Kahuna himself I don't
even know if that's a thing I just made
that up Big Kahuna Chief Kahuna I don't
even know I'll go with it uh Dave Ramsey
Rachel Cruz George Campbell Jade warshaw
John deloney and myself we are there to
help you in every area of your life it's
a two-day event I want you to unplug and
focus on those pain points where you
need some breakthrough a plan for your
money uh managing anxiety work that you
love and so much more right now for only
a couple days they're offering a special
deal admission tickets are 30 off these
are General Mission thirty dollars off
off which means they're on sale at forty
nine dollars a person so 49 bucks for
your general mission to get in the door
that means you as a couple can come in
for less than a hundred dollars you're
going to want to move fast this deal
ends next Tuesday join us in Chicago on
September 15th and 16th for smart
conference
ramseysolutions.com events
ramseysolutions.com
events let's go to Wilmington North
Carolina Brian awaits Brian how can we
help
yes good afternoon John and Ken thank
you for taking my call hope that you're
doing well today you bet what's up
yes sir I wanted to hear your input on
how to go about paying for my family
vehicle okay tell us about it
uh yes sir we have a uh made a stupid
mistake we do have a loan a car payment
um uh we have six children my wife and I
so we pursued a 12 passenger van
currently our budget is in the negative
and so we're trying to figure out what
to do with the vehicle how much you owe
on the on the van
the loan amount is right at 29 000. what
is it worth right now resale or let's go
with that one first what's the Blue Book
on it
uh yes sir for private sale I believe
the ranges in my area is somewhere 27 to
29 last I checked okay all right and
what are we going to do if we sell this
to get rid of this debt what are we
going to drive
uh yeah the plan would be we have some
money in the bank the plan would be to
purchase a van that could house our
family at our current size
um pay it with cash and be debt free
with the emergency fund right so this is
the only debt you have
besides the house yes sir right okay so
uh what's the question this sounds like
a no-brainer
uh yes sir well my wife and I we've had
you know probably four or five uh sit
down talks about it meetings as it were
and they're budget meetings that was a
nice way of saying fights so how's that
going who's who's saying so she wants a
nice she wants the safe car and you want
to get out of debt is that right
uh yes ultimately yes yeah I I
recommended we sell the car and she
would like to to keep it are we at a
standoff at this point of this phone
call
no sir we've we've talked a lot and I
think both of us are willing to we've
heard the others options and what we
want to do um but I'm not sure our
hearts are fully in it's a really I'm
wondering I I am more than willing to
keep the vehicle
um
how much do you make a year
uh yes sir it is uh right at 54 base 64
with overtime yeah you need to sell it
it's too much okay a principle we have
here is everything any anything with
wheels on it
can't be
if you took the value of everything with
wheels if you have a jet ski and jet
skis right but if you have a motorcycle
and two cars if you add them all
together that needs to be half of your
annual income
and this one van is exceeds that now I
want to go back here as I got the good
doctor to my right so I like to stir
things up when I can hand the Baton to
somebody so you said I said well have we
are we out of standoff and your reply
was no you know we we kind of kind of
you just mealy-mouthed it a little bit
and then it was like but our hearts
aren't completely in it so I want to
know the real real
because the follow-up to that immediate
comment was you said well I'm willing to
to stick with it and so I still I'm not
sure that you guys are on the same page
what's the real real
uh yes sir yes so we have talked a lot
about uh Future Family growth we both
would like to adopt one day Lord willing
so I think my wife would like to keep
the car that would allow for these
growing family
um but I'm just looking at right here
now yeah I wonder if it's the best
option um I have been doing a lot of
research into side hustles how I can
further my career
um in my full-time job as well so I'm
trying to make efforts in that way to
keep the vehicle
um so that you know my wife can feel
peaceful and comfortable and you're not
on the board yeah y'all are not only are
y'all not on the same page y'all have
very different pictures of what your
life is going to look like and you don't
need to get on that real quick because
six kids plus adopting a seventh and an
eighth and you working side hustles
every Saturday and Sunday is a recipe
for
um an implosion in your home
your wife has a yes sir you've probably
heard me say this but we think in
pictures but we speak in words and your
wife and you are both saying family and
both saying hours and she has a
radically different feeling and picture
of what family looks like than you do
and I can't imagine having six kids with
the idea of bringing a seventh and an
eighth into this family
and my solution to that to make that
happen is I'm around less
right that's a recipe for a meltdown
you have to write this thing financially
yes sir yeah we wouldn't plan to adopt
until we were financially able to of
course but it is something we considered
down the road what do you do for what do
you do for a living yeah
I work in the healthcare system on my
current position I don't have much
vertical growth I'm looking for what the
next step is what specifically do you do
in healthcare
oh yes I work in the hospital I'm
educating uh cardiac patients what do
you want to do I know you're thinking
about it
uh yeah I can I've uh I'm considering
getting your uh your get clear
assessment um that's my gift I'll give
that to you but just tell me because
when somebody laughs at that statement
when I make that 100 know the answer 100
know the answer and I don't really care
how it sounds just give it a shot for a
second we're tying this into this
question what do you want to do
no yes sir I would like to start a
um a wellness Ministry for like a better
term um that could you know Reach people
across the country what kind of Wellness
mental health all of it what
uh yeah all of it yes um I haven't quite
ironed out the details but all right I
didn't come seeing the whole person as
it were okay so can I be big brother for
just a moment
that'd be great yes sir I love your
heart behind that I think there's a
whole lot more Discovery to do in the
get clear assessment will help you fine
tune that but to start in a Ministry in
a national Ministry I come from Ministry
I grew up in it it's been in my whole
life my parents have been in Ministry
over 47 years
what you just laid out while admirable
and amazing I want to also tell you is
going to be very difficult
and in the early years and maybe the
middle years and maybe the entire year
is it is not going to necessarily be a
profitable Venture and I think you know
that and so I'm going to tie all that
back to this question and what John and
I have been telling you you and your
wife need to get on the same page big
picture of life and you need to do a
better job casting vision
and I think the money you guys have got
in the bank towards a car which is how
much you haven't told us yet how much
I'm sorry the current vehicle or the no
no how much money do you have in the
bank if we sold the van now how much you
said you had money aside to pay cash for
something else how much
just just side just over 10 came the
bank okay so here's the deal uh you're
gonna have to hustle I like to go work
and go hustle right now because I'd like
to see that go to 20 grand
how quickly can you make 10 grand
busting your butt you're gone for a
little while but mama and the kids will
be okay and I'd sell that van and I'd
buy her a nice twenty thousand dollar
van that again is serviceable it's not
ugly it's not disgusting it does what it
takes and you guys get this debt out of
your life
and just live a little bit and begin to
parent begin to plan begin to uh be
married together without all the stress
of debt do you understand what I'm
saying
yes I appreciate that yeah and the debt
has been a big burden on on me I've been
trying to maintain and watch the
finances and I see how it affects me at
home and I want to love my wife and my
kids better
um John how's he going to be able to do
the best way to love your wife and kids
quote unquote better
is it you and your wife get away and get
on the same page this isn't a matter of
better this is a matter if she's pulling
One Direction you're pulling the other
you'll got to take that energy and pull
the same direction y'all can do it man
Brian you got this hang on the line
we'll get you to get clear assessment
and uh have this conversation that John
just
recommended schedule it take the trip
and do it this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
I'm Ken Coleman I'm joined by Dr John
deloney we're here for you this hour as
we take your calls Triple eight eight
two five
5225 that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five hey we got a lot of
new people John joining us all the time
on YouTube and Via podcast and of course
radio and SiriusXM and so if you're new
to the conversation and here's talk
about baby steps and we've got these
very clear uh precise opinions on how
you should handle your money or your
work or your relationships and just
trying to figure out this whole money
journey in general go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button and just a few minutes
we're going to be able to help you see
where you are in this journey and be
able to get the tools to kind of get
caught up if you will so that you can
apply the principles and the tactics
that we give you again that's
ramseysolutions.com and click on get
started let's go to Iowa City Iowa where
Bo is on the line Bo how can we help
hi thank you guys for taking my call
sure
all right so I'll get straight to it my
room so I have a renter I'm a roommate
and he's moving out and I don't know
what to do with my house based on my
current income
okay give us the numbers
all right so I make around 40 000 1925
hourly I'm an I.T guy for a company
around here
um and my mortgage is 13.50 Ish a month
a little bit more than that he pays me
500 in rent and then half utility which
ends up being about 700 a month okay so
he's helping me out a pretty big amount
right
um and uh well he's going to be moving
out so I'm gonna be taking over the
whole thing and I'm I'd do a budget each
month
um and as right now it's just looking
great you know but then I do a budget
for after he leaves and I see that after
all my expenses I only have 400 left
over yeah why don't you just get another
roommate yeah that's what I'm wondering
so I could like
um
he's a high school friend right
um and I'm not really like my high
school friends are incredible and I
would live with none of them
but Bo's the opposite John he's like I
only living with this guy because I like
him is that what I'm hearing
right yeah so like I'm not really sure
who else I'd have move in with me who
I'm like close enough because it's
Craigslist dude you'll get a list you'll
get some incredible applicants don't do
that don't do that
gotcha and so like I know I have a few
options I've been thinking over for a
few months now looking at Advance I one
of my best friends who does not want to
move in I asked him that actually
um but he wants to buy the house from me
for about fifteen thousand dollars more
than I paid for it
um and I bought this house less than a
year ago right
um and so like I think that's an option
but like and I have like I've been told
that I'm only 21 years old right I've
been told by my mom that I can move back
in with her for a small run each month
and I have a friend in Iowa City who
um would let me move in for four are you
asking for permission to sell this house
I'm asking yes kind of so I don't think
you want determine what the I actually
see I thought he does I want to know I'm
feeling like you don't want to John
feels like you do what do you want to do
in a perfect world
um I would do not want to sell this
house that's what I feel the way you
said hold on a second the way you set up
those two scenarios I could just hear it
on you you don't want to move back with
your parents and you don't want to sell
the house for 15 more than you paid for
uh to your friend because you want to
kind of have your own house and so if if
I don't want to do something before I
decide on these options that I don't
want I want to figure out how is it that
I can do what I want and and I'm going
to tell you this is an income issue
you're doing it uh work is that it
support help desk type work
yes yep I'm the solar light internal I.T
for a company yeah bro you're 21. uh and
you've got some basic I.T skills if not
more than basic so I think there's two
things that I would I would think of
number one how do I grow in my it career
if I want to go into I.T if I want to go
into it and stay in I.T dude you're
talking about hustling a couple of side
hustles or one good side hustle some
freelance I.T work and you're making
enough money to do two things number one
uh more than have have more than 400
left okay number two
actually go you got enough to pay for
some qualifications like for instance
Bethel Tech they're a partner of the Ken
Coleman show they got a nine month
program online and for about twelve five
you could go through that program and
you're gonna be making 75 to 100 grand
out of the gate
so how could I make more money to a
have more margin and B pay for some
qualifications to move up that would be
the first two questions I'd be digging
into before I asked for permission to
sell my house to a friend or move back
with Mom and here's some simple math Man
if you get a new job or a raise for 8
400 that would increase you eighty four
hundred dollars so you said you make 40
Grand a year good if you made forty
eight five
you a little bit more cover what your
roommate's been paying you
yeah yeah
and I don't know an I.T guy on planet
Earth it makes less than 50 000. yeah
they don't work here
right this is my first this is my first
career job yes and the people who hired
you are taking full advantage of that
fact
yes and they may be maybe not in in Iowa
City I'm not but the point is John's
making the right Point here is that dude
the freelance economy right now is
massive
just go type in Google freelance economy
or freelance job market and watch the
Articles one after another going it's
hotter than it's ever been there are a
lot of small businesses in Iowa City
John that can't afford you full-time Bo
but they could afford 200 bucks a month
and so John's right I mean I
here's the point you don't want to sell
the house and you don't want to move
back in with Mom and Dad
and you don't have to
you've created a narrative that those
are your only two options or your best
two options and I don't know I'm not
sure I agree with that and let me if you
can learn this lesson I'm about to tell
you at 21 you win
and I didn't learn it until I was 40.
whenever I see an option like a set of
directions in my life and I narrow them
down to either or I'm almost always
wrong
so when you feel like there's only this
option or that option you're probably
not seeing the full field yep there's
always a third and a fourth and a fifth
option they may be ludicrous but there's
always another shot
by the way uh I don't wanna I don't
wanna brag but my fourth and fifth
options are better than your your excuse
me my three and four my three and four
are better than your first two and as a
matter of fact I want you to just give
the folks a Bethel Tech a call okay
betheltech.net Ken Coleman call them
talk to them kick the tires check out
three or four other trade schools that
are in Tech
and and by the way and then start
looking for freelance work go look at
all the help wanted ads freelance
part-time Tech work and and I think
you're gonna love life bro you're going
to have a empty house with no roommates
more money making snow angels in the
carpet dude it's gonna be awesome yes
absolutely Bogue do you believe you can
do this
I do I do all right here's the deal
permission is not ours to give John
but I'm not giving him permission to
sell this house or go live with Mom what
say you yeah I mean you're right I I got
from your voice you you wanted to sell
this thing and you had people pressuring
you not to I was I was way off man I
well yeah here's what's happening your
brain is telling you to sell the house
to just relieve the stress but your
heart is not telling you to sell the
house a man keeps telling me no yeah and
hey here's the other thing you had a
picture in your head that you two guys
are going to be roommates and Bros
forever
like dude let's get a house that'll be
awesome I'll buy it and we'll grow down
and then he moved out and now it's like
sad bro and it's all good it's the
picture change yeah it's fine it's cool
man yeah you got this man listen you're
21 with an unbelievable future ahead of
you and that's the mindset you gotta
have this is a hiccup I get it it's
totally normal to feel stressed out
about this change uh but we've got to
get on the other side of that and go
what are the best options I think you'll
be full of regret if you sell I think
you're full of regret if you live with
Mom uh and and you don't need to do any
of this get busy man take all of that
pressure and all that stress and just
put it into getting busy and making some
more money I think you're gonna be
surprised at how much of a lid you put
on yourself fascinating stuff John yeah
man
oh man I can't tell you how many times I
backed myself into a corner and I create
chaos where there doesn't need to be
it's almost never either or I love that
almost never so true love it by the way
we're here for you that's why Council
matters and if you can't uh talk to any
friends or family call us to
chuckleheads we'll give you a shot and
by the way it's free advice that you
don't have to take it he's Dr John
deloney I'm Ken Coleman it's been a
great hour I want to thank the team for
keeping us on the air and you America
for listening don't move more Ramsay
show coming up
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsey win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio this is the
Ramsey Show to where America hangs out
to have a conversation about life
specifically money
relationships mental health and work all
those are tied together more so than
ever before the phone number to jump in
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five I'm Ken Coleman
joined by my colleague Dr John deloney
and we are here for you this hour let's
go to Samantha who's on the line in Salt
Lake City Utah Samantha how can we help
thank you so much for taking my call
um I am on baby step number five and I
have nine kids whoa and I need
I know I hope you are I hope you're all
are sitting down here Samantha listen I
need you to know that sometimes I get
some feedback from Reddit that I'm
immature and I just thought of three
jokes that I did not make
Reddit so I am getting more mature by
the minute I just want you to know same
team Samantha same team so glad you're
growing although as your co-host I wish
you weren't growing right now I'd like
to hear those jokes so Samantha baby
step five for people that are joining
the audience that are really new that's
where you're saving for college how much
have you saved
about because
um actually I did the baby steps out of
order
meaning that my house has paid off and
so I've done one two three four and six
so it's really five and seven and right
now my husband
um he works at a junior college here
okay and uh he's a he's got a master's
in software engineering how much does he
make when he's not where he makes After
College he makes 82 000.
with a master's degree in software
engineering I'm going to come back to
that in a minute it's related to this
question uh go ahead keep going
uh but during the summer he does have
some high side
okay good during the summer okay and
those are those Tech related side
hustles
okay all right so again back to your
question my question have you all saved
any if you have how much for college
um we haven't saved any so zero because
zero okay great I don't have anything
for college but how old are your kids
my youngest is two my oldest is 18. so I
have and then we have two years in
between okay and you were about to say I
do have and I cut you off well what do
you have oh oh
um because he works at the junior
college he his program is a four-year
program so if our children decide to go
to the junior college and go into
software engineering they have free
tuition okay but if they don't decide to
go into software engineering then they
go the two-year College route and get
their associate's degree and then move
on to a university they have free
tuition so there's two years of school
is covered okay so that's what we do
have we just don't have anything on top
of that okay what is your question
specifically for us
so when it says save for your call your
child's college fund I did a little bit
of research on your website and it says
that to that there are like certain
funds that you can get not like Roth
IRAs but education type funds and so
with nine children and you can put 2 000
in a year that's a lot of money so I
don't know how much and I don't even
know how much to like be putting in can
I reframe this for you yes okay my head
is spinning yeah your head spinning so
number one the Utah promise is that I
think it's What's called the Utah
promise scholarship your kids all 117 of
them have free Community College
yes so as a parent congratulations
I would Breathe a deep sigh of relief ah
okay that's if that's the right path for
them
the second thing is and many many many
community colleges have everything from
English to uh like metal working that
you can get some sort of certification
in it so there's across the board here
the second thing is if they choose to go
into I.T after Dad they have a free
four-year degree taken care of
another sigh of relief
now I've seen this done with a couple of
Professor buddies of mine and with some
uh especially in the police force at
universities where men and women will
leave a like maybe they were making a
hundred grand and they take a job or
they're only making 50. but they have
three or four kids in the pipeline and
all those kids are going to go to that
college for free and if you do that math
over 10 years they're making like three
hundred thousand dollars a year whatever
it's gonna cost and so there is by
you're the way your husband is is
working for less than his market value
at that College
is on on the from another perspective
putting money in their college fund see
what I'm saying
yes okay so here's hear me and Ken say
you are worrying about something you
should not be worrying about if I'm you
okay the best I can tell you is this if
I'm you I would sit down with my 18 year
old
and I would talk about the fiscal
realities of our home
we have no money saved up here's the
here's the paths ahead of you
and that's going to be it might be a
conversation that embarrasses you or
feels a shame you you have to sit down
and give an honest
um have an honest conversation with your
kid and then talk about where are they
were they interested in doing what jobs
interest them what is what is in their
heart what do they want to go all that
kind of stuff Ken has a king Coleman has
a remarkable education
um get clear assessment for kids in
education like what what are things that
you might be interested in studying and
free community college is a great place
to start
yeah yeah right I will tell you real
quick right now I am a homeschool mom I
I do have a degree in elementary Ed with
an ESL endorsement and so I have been
homeschooling my kids and so that is one
of the things that we really do focus on
is
um just making wise decisions and so
like right now I got an eighth grader
just a daughter who just finished up
eighth grade and
um she tackles college level biology and
is taking a cup exam exactly she can get
college credit for what she's doing and
if you want to be if you want to be a
nerd my mom went to Community College
and she's 73 and she's finishing her
last year at Oxford this summer she
could you could do whatever you want to
do this whole lie that you got to go to
Stanford or you're an idiot is just
nonsense Samantha really quick give me
the rundown of the kids we have an 18
year old then what's the next one what's
the ages
I have 18 being a 16 year old daughter a
14 year old daughter a 12 year old son a
10 year old daughter an eight-year-old
daughter a six-year-old son a
four-year-old daughter and a
two-year-old daughter I thought this was
a joke you literally got pregnant every
two years that's unbelievable we should
study you and your husband when you guys
die they should donate you to science
that's unbelievable uh okay here's what
I want you to do that I've been pregnant
14 times but I had nine kids you
probably would just fall over in your
chair so bless your heart you're amazing
you're amazing so here's what I want you
to hear John's absolutely right you need
to relax I'm going to give you our brand
new Ramsey just came out with our home
study okay it's called foundations and
career Discovery it's for parents like
you to walk all those kids 18 16 14 I'd
start with them right now hang on the
line I'm going to give it to you I'm
teaching we have conversations in a
living room with real students it's
going to be great your kids do it and
you follow along and help them out and I
would be having these conversations to
decide is college the best best way for
each of these kids I think you'll be
refreshed to find out it's probably not
you guys are doing okay we're going to
walk through you I'll walk through this
process with you thank you so much for
the call hang on the line we'll get you
that curriculum foundations and career
Discovery this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things back there
washing guarantee and
hands-free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by Dr John deloney
excited to have you with us triple eight
eight two five five two two five as we
talk about your money your relationships
your mental health your work all of it
can sometimes be in one call so if you
need some help today John and I would
love to help you out uh John this is
very exciting stuff uh because your
first edition of questions for humans I
mean dude when you came up with this
idea did you foresee it uh taking off
the way it did I knew I knew every step
of the way every step of the way hey
people love the first edition of the
question for humans conversation
starters so much we went back to the
drawing board and came up with even more
ridiculous fun insightful questions to
help people grow in their relationships
and the new addition is ready for the
real world we've got all new friends
parents and kids decks couples deck so
you won't be running out of things to
talk about anytime soon this is
especially important as you hit the road
this summer it will give you something
to do in the car which is fun or taking
your kid to breakfast this summer it's
gonna be fun
um all right Ken here's a I got I want
to ask you they pulled a question from
us here now is this an actual this is
one yep okay here it is all right John
uh what unsolved mystery keeps you up at
night I feel like this is something I'd
ask Rachel Cruz our resident uh
conspiracy theorist so I I had a uh uh
This Is My Confession with Rachel I
actually a big time conspiracy theorist
and the reason the reason I I give her a
hard time is because
I'm with her the uh the unsolved mystery
that keeps me up at night what is it
I want to know the truth behind the
one-year baseball Excursion from Michael
Jordan
I think there's some stuff that went on
behind closed doors and then went behind
those closed doors and I want to know
the truth about that I gotta tell you my
friend that's delicious I didn't think I
was racking my brain what's he gonna say
I was thinking maybe some of the big
stuff like who shot Kennedy or was it
real or whatever you went with one of
the fascinating mysteries of all sports
yes because why did he leave because he
was going to get punished for the NBA
for gambling is that where you're
leaning my hypothesis is I knew there
was one that at the time he was he was
the NBA and if he goes away NBA goes
away because there's some precarious
Financial positions and but also there
was some Pete Rose Behavior going on
yeah so we had to do something
okay but we can't so you're gonna be
embarrassed for a year yeah and then you
can come back yeah I will tell you that
that's my hypothesis I like this I like
a lot because that's later information
for me I remember living through it oh I
did too and as a big basketball fan you
know I love basketball I was shocked but
I bought the whole story I bought a hook
line Sinker this is a dude who's such a
great athlete he wants to try another
because we live Bo Jackson prior to that
and Chris Gaines there you go so anyway
fascinating all right I like that I like
that all right here's my question for
you oh
is this an actual question is this
actually this makes me happy you're the
perfect person to ask this what is a
hairstyle or a personal grooming Trend
that you will never understand for
example the soul patch wow you know I
have a lot of answers that come up you
know I'm thinking back to my high school
days you remember when girls they they
would Aqua Net their bangs into a
complete incredible like straight up it
looked like almost a water fountain
coming of hair out of the sky it was
like yes that was one I didn't
understand but I'm gonna go with I'm
gonna go with the uh I'm gonna go with
the mullet even though it's really
popular now my kids are in high school
and my buddy my kids friends are wearing
these mullets and they're crushing them
I will and I never understand the mullet
I don't know if that's the question it's
a hairstyle I would say oh I think I
think that but I will also say in the
same breath while I never will
understand it I will also acknowledge
there are some dudes who pull it off is
that okay to say I think it's like the
soul patch I think no dudes pull it off
okay all right I'm I'm talking a couple
I mean not like a future yeah so there
you go all right well hey it is if you
have a mullet and sleeves you can't it
doesn't work what if you have a boat
you're going to all in mustache no
sleeves all right and then no sleeves
have to be really deep yeah right where
we're seeing too much of your stuff way
too much uh what do you think about the
mullet and the soul patch
I think that they should listen to the
Dr John deloney show because they're
working through some really deep space
well there you go folks you could get it
wherever you listen to podcasts YouTube
and more all right so hey this is just a
fun example I didn't even look to the
lobby does anybody have a mullet out
there because I don't want to get beat
up in this segment oh you wouldn't have
to it was my fault I'm the one that
talked about the mullet uh either way
you can tell these are really fun we
could do an entire show just alternating
cards uh it's a great product and so if
you want to get the second edition of
questions for humans conversation
starter cards they're on sale for only
10 bucks right now that's not even fair
let's just gotta feed his kids I love it
when it's growing gives our stuff away
yeah that's true butts is not a good
deal for you it's a good deal for
everybody else uh but you can get all
your favorite decks today by going to
ramseysolutions.com store
ramseysolutions.com store all right now
that we've thoroughly entertained
America we have to equip them Antonio is
joining us now in Houston Texas Antonio
how can John and I help
hi thank you for accepting my call I
really appreciate you guys yeah my
friend what's up
yeah so um I'm a recent college grad and
my question to you guys is should I buy
a rental property or a vehicle a rental
property or a car oh you got to give us
more information you're going big
Antonio yeah do you have any debt
Antonio
so um I have a total of ten thousand
debt five thousand from student loans
and five thousand from credit card debt
well you definitely should not buy a
rental property now now underline would
be the key word here so we want you
getting out of debt we want you paying
that debt off did you get a job
yes so um I'm currently a financial
analyst I work from home and
um I work for Verizon so I work I live
home with my parents right now and I
also don't have a vehicle I've been
paying uh I get paid weekly and I pay
half of my check goes towards my credit
I knocked my credit score I brought it
up um 47 points within the last month
um I intend on continue to knock it down
until I'm back at 30 usage rate right
now I'm around 45. all right Antonio
guess what my credit score is
what is it I have absolutely no idea
and I could care less
if I gave you one million dollars in
cash right now
your credit score would not budge no it
would not go up one point
because your credit score has absolutely
zero to do with how wealthy you are
it has to deal with what kind of
boyfriend have you been to debt over the
last X number of years
I got to get some debt so I can get a
good credit score so that then I can get
some more debt and that will help me get
a better credit score so that then I can
go borrow more money get more debt and
then I can get a better credit score it
is a circular uh roller coaster to
nowhere
so I tell you that to tell you the
quickest way to get a couple of rental
properties and actual and actually build
real wealth real money not Instagram
money real money
is pay off your debts take advantage of
living in Mom's house I would put 90 of
my check if not 98 of my check and get
all this debt knocked out ASAP and then
I'd buy me the most ridiculous beater
car I could possibly get away with
driving
and I would stat cash and stack cash and
stack cash and stack cash
that's what I would that's what I do in
my house let me let me put it that way
and I know that's not sexy and that does
not play on Tick Tock very well at all
and that is the fastest path to being
truly wealthy
all right how does that hit you Antonio
what are you thinking and feeling
um you know I've been battling with it
because
um I've been in the hall well in the
house since the pandemic started so it's
been three years and
um with me not having to have a vehicle
and working from home
um I felt a lot of stagnation and I feel
like it's um taking a negative toll on
my mental health absolutely
yeah but I was one of the reasons
Antonio listen I just bought a car for
my 17 year old so I I just paying
attention to stuff all the time
and do you know you can get a decent car
and I mean decent it doesn't have to be
a piece of crap on Wheels but a decent
car for five to six grand
so how long would it take you to save up
that money and get yourself a car
it wouldn't take me long wouldn't take
you long no and it wouldn't take you
long to pay off this debt like John said
and they go get go get a one bedroom
apartment put a nine month cap on this
or six to nine months by the time
Christmas is I'm moved out I owe nobody
nothing and I got me a car I'm gonna go
get a one bedroom apartment I'm gonna
start from there yeah it's time for you
to start living Antonio the good news is
you can start living but no to the
rental property until you pay cash hey
cash pay cash pay cash all right so your
best is yet to be my friend it's time to
get out and start living I love the call
I appreciate the call and we're rooting
for you my friend you got this this is
the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
show I'm Ken Coleman joined by Dr John
deloney we're here for you this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to the City
of Angels Los Angeles California Calvin
joins us Calvin how can we help
hey guys thanks for taking the call you
bet what's going on Calvin
so about two years ago I actually gave
my brother and his girlfriend about a 25
000 loan to help them buy a house and
in the time since uh he's actually
giving me back his half but she's only
paid me back like 2 000 of it oh and so
I'm kind of wondering how can I bring
this up without it being like a huge
family fight you cannot I was gonna say
What's it been like tell John uh what's
it been like so far because if your
brothers paid his share but she hasn't
there's got to be some conversations
what do we know tell us what we don't
know
so I've talked to him about it and
basically what he told me is he has the
money she's capable of paying it back
but she's just choosing not to and he
can't explain to me why and someone
excited yeah and it's his wife he
doesn't want to talk trash about your
sister
he knows I guess but but how yeah I
don't know how to bring it up you you
cannot bring it up without it becoming a
thing you gotta you gotta you gotta put
that aside
you can do one of two things
you can say
congratulations sister I just gave you
twelve thousand dollars to buy a house
and I'm moving on with my life and you
can internally know I'll never give you
money ever again for us till the end of
time
or you can sit down and say it's been
this long and
um I need to we need to we need to lay
out a payment plan and put it in writing
when I need this money back
and she can lose her mind and get mad
and all that and such it is those are
your two choices man
yeah the thing is he she has the money
it doesn't matter she's not paying you
you know why because she doesn't have to
laughs yeah you just gotta make a
decision am I gonna do this one or am I
gonna do this one
but I wanna I wanna ask a question
Calvin John just laid out two really
awesome clear options and your response
was but she has the money what does that
have to do with what he said there's
something you're still tripping up on
what do you what do you mean by that why
is that your response to him
when I gave him the loan I didn't
realize I was giving half of it to her I
thought it was just a loan between me
and my brother
and and I wouldn't personally have given
her the money but now that I then he
told me after that they're going to pay
it back half and half so I just feel
like I got a little bit duped the other
side of this is so I I misunderstood I
was thinking this was your sister and
your brother-in-law paid this is your
brother and his wife
yeah his girlfriend his girlfriend his
girlfriend which makes it even weirder
um let's let me tell you this if some
weird twist of fate I had borrowed money
from my brother
um with my girlfriend to buy a house
I would feel some sort of obligation for
the other half especially if I'm still
living in this house
I think he does and he's brought up that
he wants to pay back but she won't let
him because she doesn't want to owe him
rather than me but now it's just coming
this twisted like
I do think your brother's playing you
that's what you feel and I'm starting to
lean that way John am I wrong I would
get so far away from them dude
your brother's not treating you with
Integrity their relationship is weird I
don't want to owe the guy that I'm
creating a life with and sharing a house
then then they've got deeper issues than
than this dude thanksgiving's not worth
this how close are you two
we we're extremely close like he's like
my best friend does that change it John
he's your best friend except that he
doesn't tell you the truth and he uh
isn't like a person of character when it
comes to borrowing money
he is but he accepts that he's not
scared out of the conversation with her
or what no no no here's here's it Calvin
I'm asking John a question on your
behalf okay I do believe
that that in in Calvin's mind his
brother is his best friend I hear what
you're saying I don't think the
brother's acting like a true best friend
agreed however
I'm asking this from a completely like
just common sense if this were my
brother and I have a brother
um and we were close
it would be it would be on like Donkey
Kong like dude
you figured out with a girlfriend you
duped me you this you this you this this
ain't right I'm gonna do this to your
girlfriend right I'll just call the
brother card I feel like this is a
man-to-man I didn't say ugly or or nasty
or physical but am I wrong this changes
the equation no I think you got to call
the brother card out and go Brothers
don't do this to each other dude you got
to solve this brother's got a hug man
yeah you owe me the money and you
figured out with girlfriend but him
choosing girlfriend over you I think's a
cop out and I'd call the brother card
that would be me and then do what John
said but at the end of the day you got
to choose am I am I just gonna wash my
hands of this stuff and move on with my
life or am I gonna am I gonna cause a
scene there is no there's no like right
or wrong answer there
but listen yeah keep this
sentence in your mind for the rest of
your life behavior is a language
and what your brother is telling you is
that he thinks he's above you
and he doesn't really care that you
bailed him and his girlfriend out to buy
a house
and your brother's girlfriend is telling
you I couldn't care the last second
about you so true I don't like you I
don't care about you I took your money
and hahaha
that's what their behavior is telling
you
and that and listen to me like carefully
that hurts man like beneath me and Ken
like beneath me joking and being that
hurts because brothers are not supposed
to treat each other that way people that
you loan money to to help out are
supposed to be people of integrity and
pay their money back
and that just hurts
have you called him out at all I mean
real real I've talked to him but every
time we talk it just turns into oh I
don't know she just doesn't want to yeah
I can't get any further than that that's
why I'm getting the point do I just call
her and talk to her absolutely yeah
yeah I think he's kicked a can to you
anyway and and well I actually love what
you just said that's actually phenomenal
is that yours or somebody else's case I
steal it I need to give credit what's
that behavior is a language yeah that's
just across the board yeah I like the
way you said it yeah my point is is that
I think his behavior
is telling his brother like the the
Calvin's brother is saying I'm kicking
the key into her absolutely I don't want
to deal with this confrontation if you
do call her call her with some very
specific requests don't call her and be
like hey when are you uh
call her and say I need the
um full amount of this repaid by this
date or what
I'm going to call the small claims court
I'm going to fill in the blame
and are you ready to walk are you ready
to fight for this
no I don't really need the money it's
more just like the disrespect I guess of
her not caring about it
and him not carrying you keep letting
him off the hook man he's a part of this
I think he's the culture that's what I'm
thinking I might just forget about it
well I didn't say you had to do that I
was just curious where your spirit was
on this because John's giving you great
advice here you know walk away or give
it one last shot but you got to decide
it's got to be one of the other you need
closure yes
yeah they just they keep bringing up
like they're going to remodel their
house they're trying to buy a second
house and it's just getting in the
playroom like that's why I do more about
that stuff they're just spitting on you
man yeah I gotta know why why are you
letting your brother off the hook here
because I love the guy like I want him
to be happy you know I love my brother
with all my heart but there's also
accountability
yeah that's true
John I feel like he's gonna go from
loving to resenting here soon you are
about to yeah and uh this is from the
greatest at parel
always
always choose guilt over resentment
every time
because what you don't want to do is
wake up in three years and hate your
brother
and if she turns into his wife and their
kid turns into your nephew you don't
want to hate them
and so choose guilt over resentment
every time
feel guilty about making the call and
being very direct and putting down some
things in writing
it's going to feel weird it's going to
feel guilty because like you said I love
him I want him to have be happy and have
a good life absolutely and
you want him to do what he said he was
going to do
I'm sorry man that's I I'm just my
heart's broken I'm Hearts broken for you
it's real life and it happens here
caller after caller on the Ramsey Show
don't move more coming up
[Music]
foreign
welcome back America you've joined the
conversation here on the Ramsey show a
conversation about your life and your
money
specifically how your money is helping
you live truly freely because you owe
nothing to anybody and you live the life
you want your relationships your work
everything else ties into all of that
and we're here to answer your questions
in all three of those areas I'm Ken
Coleman he is Dr John deloney the phone
number to jump in is triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
our question of the day is sponsored by
neighborly your hub for Home Services if
you're moving you have a long list of to
Do's but neighborly has local Pros like
house Master five star painting window
Genie and Junk King to check items off
that list visit neighborly.com today to
schedule home service experts near you
all right today's question comes from
Dennis in Washington Dennis writes I
have a hundred and forty thousand
dollars in student loan debt from my MBA
ouch my only other debt is my mortgage
and because of the pause I have kicked
the can down the road on paying my
student loans when evaluating my budgets
for when or if they resume they will I
will be miserable yes and it gives me
anxiety yes I make a hundred and ten
thousand dollars at my current job and I
found other full-time jobs where I can
make a hundred to 130k I was thinking
again anytime somebody says I was
thinking I know I was thinking wait for
it is it ethical or normal to consider
I like how he conflated the two is it
ethical or normal to consider doing both
remote jobs at once combined I could
make two hundred and thirty thousand
dollars if not more I figure if I do
this I can pay off my student loans in
17 to 24 months in five years I can be
completely debt free with a net worth of
nearly three quarters of a million
dollars I'd like to hear your thoughts
well first of all it is normal
uh for people to think how can I make
more money and we saw real cases of this
I've talked about it on the Ken Coleman
show certainly during the pandemic and
we've talked about here on the Ramsey
show as well where there are still
people doing this and uh especially in
technology where they are fully serving
both companies and they are knocking
down two full-time jobs but the other
companies don't know about it so is it
normal yes is it ethical in my opinion
no with the one caveat where I actually
have seen this John and it's extremely
rare So when I point this out I want to
point out it's extremely rare where both
companies did know about it and the the
two supervisors or managers were okay
but it's a very rare situation uh in the
in and so it's unethical I call it
professional polygamy ooh okay until
unless the companies are aware of it and
are okay which is extremely you need to
tell both people you got to tell them
both okay and no one wants to do that no
because you risk a situation there so
it's not ethical it's cheating it's
professional polygamy it's Sister Wives
you pick the analogy uh it's just not
right and and the reason it's not right
is most of the time when you're trying
to pull this off
you aren't making people aware of it now
John I can tell you I've been doing this
long enough
I'm going to anticipate some objections
right now and so let's go through them
one objection is oh wait a second I
wonder if one is during the day and I
work one at night okay great fantastic I
still think both companies need to know
about it I just do and so if you're not
telling them which means you are
withholding from them I believe that
that is unethical that's one objection
well wait a second I can truly get both
jobs done I am truly serving both I all
right again
you're not telling them you're
withholding it's a it's unethical it's
not the right thing to do and uh you can
make a lot of financial sense out of it
I don't think you can make any moral
sense out of it so for me
um
yes I understand it it can be done and
it is being done I don't think it's
right
the bigger concern here for Dennis and
Washington
or my fear for this guy is this he has
created a world he has created a mess
for himself
and he created a mess for himself
probably since he's got a hundred and
forty thousand dollar NBA he's probably
a smart guy
and he came it it feels like the um the
Bro Science the uh he did some great um
Beanie Baby math here it's like oh if I
do this I get my NBA and then they're
gonna then they're gonna um just cancel
out the loans and then suddenly it's
three years later from this big promise
and like we've been telling you and
telling you it hadn't come through yet
and now people like Dennis are starting
to realize oh I may have to pay all this
back that's right and the other day
um on the Ramsey Show Dave and I went
through an article and again hat tip to
the great Tyler Cowan from marginal
Revolution
again I was stunned so there's there's
two different Loan Servicing paths for
it if you will one of them is the loans
the student loans are made by the
government the other is made by Banks
and guaranteed by the government so when
the pause came in
the government only has authority to
pause one of them that's not the other
one that's correct so you've got an
instant for researchers an instant
randomized control group some people got
it paused and some didn't and when they
went and studied those like right now
they just studied them and this was an
economic white paper at a DC these are
the top of the top guys I love this
stuff
what they found was those that did not
receive a pause there were not
additional delinquencies
they I I wish there was a more fancy way
to say this they figured it out they
looked at reality and said this sucks
and they figured it out when their jobs
were going away when they had couldn't
work they figured it out
the other folks who got the pause
increased their debt by approximately
five percent how per household that's
Madness it's crazy because what they did
was they had extra liquidity in their
home extra cash and they put they use
that for down payments on cars on new
houses or on like other they spent that
money oh yeah and it propped up the
economy for a second and then it further
trapped those people down down the
stream right so dude you've created a
mess for yourself and I wish there was a
hack here Tyler
there's one hack and that is to get a
machete and head into the jungle and
carve yourself a path man and that is
paying the stuff off it's going to take
you a long time because you dug yourself
a huge hole or find a job that pays you
250 000 in an ethical way right all
right I want to stay here okay I want to
go back to what you just said with the
white paper yeah is it a lot of people
listening and watching brand new to this
whole discussion and I think this is a
psychology thing and I know you know it
so I'm gonna so I want to dig all right
so the people that were believing
shall we say hoping
wishing I'm giving you three
psychological states that Uncle Joe or
congress were going to wipe their debt
clean they ended up spending more money
what is going on psychologically there
when someone knows they got dead hanging
over them they are hoping wishing
believing but they still go out and take
on more debt or they spend more what is
happening in The Human Condition there
there is a you take a breath
and the fear of I'm about to get eaten
goes away okay and you just instantly
fall back to homeostasis you go back to
the way things were and the way things
were was I bought whatever I wanted
whenever I wanted it we also didn't take
into account there was a pause and but
people were one year into the degree so
they kept going to school taking out
more loans and more so the whole thing
was a is a mess but I think there was a
group of people the world started
shutting down and remember the dominoes
falling and everything impacted this
this this and this and this
I remember that it was scary it was
scary
and then they came in and said you don't
have to pay this month you don't have to
pay indefinitely
and everybody exhaled
and then someone said hey look at this
new car and we are off to the new next
new thing
the other folks who did not have a pause
didn't have that luxury they had to
figure out the scary reality they were
in okay so what happened there then
chemically and maybe it's not chemical
but what's going on in the brain where
you're in a fight or flight or you're in
a you're in a state of because you said
they relaxed the people that's right so
what happened is I just want our
audience to understand that this money
game we got to understand how we're
wired and when we sense some relief is
that what happened they were like oh I
may not have to pay it and then they
just said I got options now in the
moment you have options okay every
business in the world comes after you
because they know you got cash in your
cars and I'm not better I'm not I can't
defeat the the neuroscientists and the
tech folks and the sales people who have
all banded together to right hump me
full of ads every day right I can't beat
them and so the moment I exhale whom
yeah when I'm looking at math and I
can't feed my family yeah then I can
defeat Those ads yeah because I got to
feed my family right it's a scary moment
so my takeaway my Layman takeaway is
when it comes to debt you cannot relax
on it that fight or flight is a good
thing you need that intensity to be able
to push through the Temptation that's
what I'm taking life yes absolutely all
right there it is there's psychology
around money folks let's not forget it's
awesome beautifully I know hey
that's why I asked you you got the PHD
baby he is Dr John Delaney I'm Kim
Coleman I want to say thanks to all the
guys in the booth for keeping us on the
air and you America for listening this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show that's where America hangs
out to have a conversation about life
specifically your money
your mental health your relationships
and your work they're all tied together
isn't that interesting I'm Ken Coleman
joined by Dr John Maloney the toll-free
number to jump in is AAA
825-5225 that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five you got a
fabulous audience uh in the lobby of
Ramsey Solutions uh people are just
fired up they're clapping or air
clapping they're giving John The Rock
sign what is that thing that you do is
that is that called something or is it
just the universal sign for I like rock
and roll what is this I think it depends
on what kind of mood you're in it's
adaptable I think it's adaptable all
right good because you make it's your
thing I just it's a real setting I do a
lot of rock and roll shows yeah it just
happened you do you go to those things
yeah I'm always inspired by like here I
am I'm sitting on my back porch watching
Golf and I'll pull up Instagram and
John's at a mosh pit and I'm thinking to
myself
it's not me when I was a kid I'm
impressed when I was a kid there was
always one old guy in the mosh pit and
now I realized the other day I was like
oh I'm the guy it's that guy yeah and
I'm sitting there going out of
admiration but I'm also going yeah it's
a little too loud and sweaty for me it's
very loud and very sweaty I like the
golf the guy talks like this now putting
25 foot Putt and you want noise and
sweat and it's fantastic
my counselor recently asked me where is
a place that like you can be fully
you and I was really the mosh pit yeah
well I don't have to be on like you got
to be on for he at work you got to be on
yeah oh it's right there it's there I'll
tell you one other place that I've had
the unfortunate reality to witness is uh
on the back of Dave's ski boat when
we're tubing and he's trying to murder
us and I'm next to the tube and John and
John we're both in our 40s and John is
trying to come off of his tube and climb
onto mine and all I can think about is
John's significant knee or elbows going
into my face and killing me and he's
like a two-year-old out there he's
having so much fun I'm like be safe no
my favorite my favorite comment you've
ever made to me was hey knock it off
so true
I guess like we're going 80 miles an
hour down a lake yeah and I'm jumping
tubes by the way if you wonder if you
wonder if Dave is gentle in dragging the
tubes no he's truly trying to maim us uh
it is it is quite the scene to behold
but enough of that let's get to your
calls Gabriel's joining us in Atlanta
Georgia Gabriel how can we help
good afternoon gentlemen how you doing
we're having a blast what's up
hey uh my question is how do I get my
wife and I to be on the same page where
our sweating happens tell me about your
spinning habits
well right now for the past month we've
been on a budget and it's going great I
mean seeing where our money is going
uh the thing is I'm getting a new job
I'm starting this coming week and my
wife just started a new job last week
and we're basically gonna be making more
money than we ever have uh together
and so I mean that's a great blessing
um Just for information what are you
guys going to be making together
so combined is about 90 300. great free
tax and free benefits you know like
Health Care
congratulations I have a second job uh
which I estimate I can make about 30
000. doing that second job as well is
that in addition to the 90 combined
correct in addition
right we're forty two thousand five
hundred dollars in debt
and I estimated our annual spending this
is just our four walls and what it takes
to take care of our dog
um is about 48 380.
12 000 of that is the uh dok fund
um
which is uh the God Only Knows fund
so okay could you explain that a little
bit more is that your emergency fund
no no that that's going to be our annual
spending the 12K there that's just like
I just I don't know exactly how I really
don't know how my spending has been
until now
so I was like you know what I'm just
gonna say as through that budget or that
annual budget a thousand dollars for you
know breaks on the car or an emergency
vet visit or you know all right here's
the deal here's the deal
you can
total total debt is 40 000 about is that
what you said
correct 42 000. okay
so you can do one of two things and you
and I will still be friends kin too
okay is that cool I'm not ready to
commit to that yet okay oh I'll still be
your friend I'm kidding of course you
can do one of two things
thing number one
is you can look at your finances and
your new marriage and new jobs and y'all
can come up with a plan that works for
you and your family and your home that's
great knock your lights out go get them
we'll still be friends we'll still hang
out all that's cool
or you can take the simplest most direct
path that millions of people have done
and get your butt out of debt and start
having the marriage and the sleep and
the hooking up with your wife and the
vacations and the families that you want
to have
you can pick
yes that's actually funny to say that
because I feel like I want to go 80
miles an hour uh just full gunning it
and my wife kind of wants to go 30. okay
I could already tell you why can I tell
you why she wants to do that
because it's Gabriel's plan nope because
you are going 85 miles an hour in 50
different directions you don't even know
you've got the God Only Knows fund and
I'm not sure you explained it well but
I'm gonna take a stab he doesn't even
know what it is you don't even know it's
just a lump sum of money every month
that you're not sure where it's coming
from so my friend your opening question
was how can my wife and I get on the
same page and the answer is you can't
get on the same page when you don't even
know what's on your page you're throwing
like you're gonna like throwing books at
her and you're like why don't you read
these books and she she's dodging books
I think she's going slow down bro we
don't even know what's in the God only
known God Only Knows fun I think she's
right by the way
is so so yeah so the God only knows one
that's just like it's like that we don't
know what's going to happen you know
when exactly we're gonna need the tires
or maybe something further okay well
that's different
but listen listen to me listen to me
yes sir one thousand dollars in a in a
savings account
that's it and it should scare the crap
out of you you shouldn't be able to
breathe
because you only have a thousand dollars
in Savings in every other Penny goes to
paying that 40 Grand off what is the 42
40 we only got about a minute give me
real quick what's the 42 Grand
so 42 Grand is uh
23 uh
23 000 is uh student loans
8 000 is cars
another eight thousand is credit card
and then the wrestler is a bit
miscellaneous between my brother and all
right here's the deal um here's the deal
you make really good money
you just laid out a 120 000 rough
roughly 120 000 income you guys should
be able to crush this very quickly no
more what about this what about that
it's we're gonna sign up now here's the
deal I need a yes or no answer do you
want to do it the way that we've taught
millions of people to do it yes or no
yes sir all right hang on the line what
are we giving him John we're going to
give you Financial Peace University the
whole class all the lessons and I'm
going to give you and your new wife the
every dollar app premium version that
will link with your bank for a year
we're hooking you up you got to watch
every lesson and you got to decide we're
gonna do this path the right way and
then in no time at all you're going to
be free man you're gonna be free ah I
can already I can already hear him
snoring with peace Financial Peace good
stuff hey thank you young man for the
call Gabriel your best is yet to be I
promise this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back America you've joined the
Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman I'm joined
by my colleague Dr John deloney and John
and I have the uh really fun privilege
on our Building Wealth tours we've been
out on the road some of you have been to
these events we have uh I guess they
call it a pre-session before Dave comes
out and speaks and uh we really just sit
there on two chairs and we take
questions live from the crowd and
obviously John is in the area of mental
health and relationships and and then
I'm in the area of work and and you just
can't talk about mental health these
days without talking about work because
a lot of times work the area where we
spend most of our Lives is very very
stressful in a not healthy environment
and that has obvious impact on your
mental health which then if you're not
handling all that well you're dragging
that stuff at home and so we take those
questions so John I shared this data on
my show today and I and I wanted to
bring it in because again this is this
is uh fascinating stuff
the number two Google not gurgle Google
the number two Google search phrase
um
with the blank I'm feeling blank at work
so this is a pretty popular search I'm
feeling
blank at work and the number two uh
search phrase is left out
then what to talk about at work is being
searched more than ever in the U.S so as
they look at the trends here this is
a clear Trend now it's not just a
workplace issue how to make friends
where to meet people
both of those phrases currently at all
time highs so what we're talking about
here is when someone is searching for uh
I'm feeling left out at work give me
some help there is a Longing To Belong
there's a longing for connection
um and let's add one more to this pile
to get you to weigh in how to make
friends is currently 70 higher than how
to make more money yeah so I let off on
today's show where I focus on work it
was a little bit of a uh bait and switch
but it was not the switch and it was
more people are searching for friends
than they are raises
yeah and the data doesn't lie no I think
the conversation we're having
globally and culturally about this
loneliness epidemic the idea that when
your body recognizes it is lonely you
don't have anybody to call the middle of
the night to keep your kids if your wife
gets sick you don't have anybody to come
over to your house and help you move a
couch you don't have anybody to fill in
the blank
you don't have anybody to call think
right now if you're sitting somewhere
quietly think right now
you get a call that your mom or dad
passed away who would you call
and if you have to think more than two
seconds
there's probably a chance your body is
trying to get your attention yeah and so
everybody's reading this data and it's
coming out all over the place
everybody's talking about loneliness
which is awesome
but it doesn't cover over the fact that
we've got nowhere to go so people are
going to work and trying to solve this
like
uh how do I make I'm left out at work I
don't how do I even connect and then it
goes to a tools issue I don't know how
to do this right well our skills issue I
don't know how to do this yeah and I
don't I don't I don't know that it's a
hundred I don't know that it's they're
trying to solve it at work it's just we
spend more time that's where they go
with other people and so anytime I'm
engaged in something yes and I'm a part
of other humans I'm trying it's the
lateral I see yes where am I at in this
whole deal and and we need connection
now does your best friend in the world
need to reside at work I don't think so
yeah it's fine if it is it's not needed
but the idea of just having a connection
and it was Stark to me that this is what
people are searching I feel left out and
there is a growing movement I don't know
if you've seen this I share a lot of
this on my show because I've been
fighting this issue because I just don't
think you can Thrive at work and grow
professionally and financially just
speaking on pure Financial and
Professional growth if you are isolated
at work you can do a good job yes but
there's a growing movement on social
media where it's like I'm just gonna go
to work I'm gonna do my job I don't want
to be friends with anybody and we're not
saying you got to go to happy hour every
night with people you work with but
while you're there
you need human connection true or false
one thousand of course and yet people
aren't feeling that way and so what's
interesting is that people are searching
this so I'm bringing this up to you to
go what's Your Gut take as to why that
many people are going uh I need some
tools and tips on how to not be left out
what's happening there I'm gonna go back
to again the same advice I give people
when they call
and they say my kid doesn't like me so I
don't even call them anymore
you're the parent it's your job to
bridge that relationship very similarly
it's very easy for leaders all across
the country and CEOs to point at their
employees and say they're just quitting
and cashing out
have you made an environment
where they feel unified towards a common
Mission and they're rewarded in the
right way and they are seen and they are
appreciated and they're heard these days
of I'm gonna slash and burn costs until
my employees those are over Yep they're
over your business is gonna fail
underneath you it's going to be replaced
by somebody online period I I had
somebody uh recently I bought some
guitars from a guy and he as I was
leaving he looked at me and he said
thank you for buying from us
and it was a sense that you can got get
stuff anywhere you can get it anywhere
now you chose us thank you and I want
every CEO to understand that choice is
continuing to expand and expand and
expand
I I can for the life of me I don't
understand the resistance to what if we
actually made coming to work a place
where people wanted to be I I don't get
it I don't understand it I don't either
because every data point says you'll
sell more you'll make more yeah I don't
understand it by the way for the leader
who's failing to get this your ability
lead is going to be a lot greater and
you're going to get more done less
stress for you when you got people who
want to tow their end of the line but
here's here's two things I want to get
your take on
and I shared this on my show today on
this I think that there's this left out
creep
has snuck up on some people
and what I mean by that is I'm not sure
it's a conscious Choice all the time but
I think people are the I love that you
said it's kind of on you the parent if
your kids aren't talking to you and I
think on on these people searching this
on some level there's some things they
can do and I think that social media has
made us less social we're connected
but we're disconnected we're connected
to information about all the people
we're communicating but we're not
connected yeah that's yes thank you and
then I think there's something else I I
wrote this down I think that because of
social media now this is not the update
In the comparison and the connect it's
just I'm now more aware of things
and 24-hour news I feel like our country
and I think the pandemic lit it on fire
I think it was happening and I think the
pandemic made it about you're either a
mask vax person or you're not and I
think politics was already that way I
think politics is even worse and so
we're at a point now where it's like I
can't be friendly with someone who I
fundamentally disagree with on this this
and this and I think I guess what I'm
saying is I'm afraid that polarization
societal issues politics Faith pick the
topic
I think polarization is pulling us apart
and I think it's isolation is a result
of polarization I I don't know if I'm
right it just feels like that's part of
it because I go to the office and I go I
could be friendly to this guy but I
heard him talk about this guy yeah it's
one step before that I I think it's hard
to even know anymore
and so because everybody's going I don't
want to share what instead of sharing my
because because it it it it distills
down to three or four issues right on
either side of the aisle of course these
three or four things that's right
and I'm afraid to put mine out there
because I don't know what you're where
you are on these three or four things
forget the 45 million things that we
have in common it's these four things
that tell the world you're on this team
or this team and so we just Turtle up
and you Turtle up for six months a year
which is by the way you're right because
what to talk about at work is being
searched and I think that's people going
what can I okay yeah can I talk how do I
how do I how do I I haven't done this
for one year two years three years I
don't have the skills how do I go back
and do this and that's where I'm going
to go to the leader it's it's the it's
the leader's job it's the boss's job to
create an environment where people are
interacting create just try it just try
it yeah what if you made a business for
90 days your employees could not wait to
get there yeah I promise you'll make
more money even if it costs you more
money out the gate and for those of you
trying to search feeling left out or
what to talk about here's one thing talk
about other people everyone's favorite
topic is themselves asking about their
family their friends their lifestyle
hobbies and best guess what you're gonna
find people that you connect to and just
be a human you don't have to be an
expert in some topic this is the Ramsey
Show
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey show where we talk
with you about your life specifically
your money your relationships and your
work I'm Ken Coleman he is Dr John
deloney the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
all right let's go oh wait a second I
gotta mention something John this is
pretty exciting now years ago
Stacy and I we've taught two financial
peace or we facilitated rather two FPU
classes back in Atlanta when we lived
there and with some of the most
life-changing fun stuff we still stay in
contact with some of the couples that we
met in those classes and certainly
something that changed our life and if
you haven't heard this John Rachel j
George and myself were all teaching
uh facilitating Financial Peace
University class as they're calling it
take FPU with a personality and uh so uh
mine is coming up
um and this is going to be a lot of fun
I did my prep yesterday John sign up for
Ken's class sign up well I was nervous
that I would even be able to operate the
zoom if I'm being completely honest but
oh I've got a guy helping me the crack
course at a team over there and then I
know that Alex is incredible unless is
going to be with me on making sure Alex
is with me he got out he basically make
sure I'm in the century I'm having a
blast and yeah sign up for Ken's class
so what's one of the what's one of the
most fun things that's happening for
years you're sitting there the level of
vulnerability people they came to they
they came to to play they came to be
serious and so they want to change their
life fantastic well I'm gonna be joining
it's going to be a Wednesday evening and
Friday evening uh course option and it
starts next week so if you want to jump
in and that's a good time frame for you
go to fpu.com that's fpu.com and you'll
find the class uh with me we'll see you
there Jeremy's up next in Raleigh North
Carolina Jeremy how can we help
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
uh I am I have a question regarding or
really for Ken and uh career-wise but
currently I'm about two years into my
MBA and um I am considering switching uh
to my MSA my master of science in
accounting okay uh my career path is to
be a controller with my CPA
certification and so just wanted to get
Ken's perspective on that yeah okay so
um you're two years into the NBA how
much time is left and then the second
part of the question is I'm assuming
you've done the homework and what would
happen like do you add what would
transfer what would transfer over to the
MSA
so I'm about two years in I have about
another year and a half left with my MBA
okay I'm actually with the with the
change from MBA to MSA would also be
transferring schools uh just a better
better program and uh so if I were to
completely change to the MSA it would be
about three three and a half years if I
were to continue my MBA and then get my
master of science in accounting it would
be about four years okay and how much
additional money to move over to the MSA
how much out of your pocket uh well
that's yeah so that would be the great
thing is my employer just came out and
offered that they'd pay for it so up
until this point I've been cash flowing
it but now uh my employer would be
willing to pay for it uh they would be
willing to pay to finish my MBA and then
go on to my MSA but in the homework that
I've been doing about switching uh I've
started to have this consideration of
just you know
for going the NBA and going right to the
MFA can you sit for your exams with your
MBA I know a lot of controllers that
have mbas I do too
uh you can at full you just just to be
well at least for the state of North
Carolina you have to have uh 20 graduate
accounting hours aside from your basic
accounting classes so it's it changes or
varies from state to state
um but I know for North Carolina the MSA
gets you very close to what you need for
that do you want to know I'm saying can
you contr can you finish your MBA in a
year and sit for these exams
I don't believe with the course of study
I'm in currently uh it is possible and
sure maybe with a different tailored
plan you know an MBA in accounting with
an emphasis in accounting or so that's
what I know for sure I I need you to get
sure I I I'm just telling you I'm
thinking I'm trying to run through the
controllers I know personally they all
have mbas
and so sure maybe they just say they
have MBA because they don't explain what
MSA is but I think you can if you have
enough graduate hours in accounting
which in an MBA class you should
man I because here's what I want you to
look at I want you to look at lost time
too yeah we talk about like a um a
degree costs this much money this takes
us long to do it but you lose the wages
you could learn on the back end too
while you're in school and so I right
there's just a cost to your life man so
there's a lot here on paper that you
gave us
um
but I what I don't understand if do you
want to stay at this company long term
your current company is willing to pay
okay and so are they willing they're not
willing did I understand they're not
willing to pay for the finishing of the
NBA they're only willing to pay for the
NBA if you then go on to the MSA did I
understand that correctly
they would pay for they open the door to
me to figure out what I want to do and
they'll pay for my schooling
okay well to John's point I'm not sure
you answered my question but I I want
you to dig into can I make a couple
adjustments on the MBA program and not
have to do the MSA because I think
John's right the time on this it's a lot
of schooling and and if they like you
and value you and they want you to move
up the ladder I would get their take on
it as well that's why I asked do you
want to be there long term because it
sounds to me like they value enough to
offer this and they see a path of growth
which I love this but I just think you
have to look at both situations and I'm
going to do what I do a lot of times on
my show I you called to ask us but I
think you have a pretty good gut feeling
and I want to know which way you're
leaning
I would say with the MSA just because
that was in the MSA program that I'm
looking at would give me would get me
three out of the four uh
tests through the CPA exam perfect and
then it would be up to me and you can
carry your job but you could still win
at the job and still move up
yes sir all right so I sounds like I've
been talking out of both sides of my
mouth that's exactly what I did I had my
degree and I went another four plus
years of five years
the company paid for it and that's what
I did so if you can pushed you and you
answered as far as I'm concerned you
answered that the right way I think he
did this is in your soul you're gonna
come out here with it with almost all
the way to licensure that makes a lot of
sense to me and the reason I'm slam dunk
on it is because he wants to be there
long term and they've proven they want
him the only the only thing I would
challenge you on as just a guy from
higher ed is
just the currency of an MBA is different
than an MSA you can tell somebody at a
cocktail party hey I've got MBA and they
might be looking for somebody XYZ and
you're gonna go oh okay so if you're
this close to the end of that credential
man I I would take a long hard look at
that before I walked away from an NBA
MSA if you're right there and somebody's
paying for it that's just that's just
something to consider you consider me
coming back to my NBA after I finish
Mandy and I think yes I'm I'm a slight
disagreement with my friend but he's
also comes from an academic world where
he's in conversations where people give
a crap about an NBA uh I I hang out with
business people that don't give a crap
and I think that if you want to move up
the ladder so it's not that I I don't
disagree with John I'm just saying I
think the MSA is the move if you want to
come back later and get the NBA after
you find out if it matters or not but I
also understand the spirit of which he's
saying it you're already in it uh but I
want you to get on the right ladder and
uh I think you're gonna make the right
call either way but I I just tell you
this the training to get the exams to
get the promotions somebody's paying for
it that's all that's why that's why I'm
in agreement with you on moving to the
MSA but neither one neither choice is
going to be bad for you you're a rock
star and can I just compliment you it's
a big stinking deal when a company is
willing to pay for that kind of
education that means they're investing
in you and I hope you walk taller
tonight because that's that's really
great really proud of you
yeah thank you guys I appreciate it yeah
you bet interesting stuff there you know
and I think I think more people ought to
go to their companies and go hey here's
an idea don't be don't be you know
arrogant about it don't be demanding but
just go hey if I were to go get this
would you be willing to invest in me
because I'd like to be here here's a uh
something I did
um I didn't even go that route I said
hey you provide this much professional
development you fly me to a conference
every year and it costs about 2500 bucks
all in right that's what the cost of one
graduate class is can I trade because I
think this class would be a better for
our company and my boss went done no not
even done absolutely and that that ended
up being a great thing for us wow I love
it that is good stuff there hey uh
really really fun call there I love that
all right don't move we got more of your
calls coming up this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back America you're joining the
conversation here on the Ramsey Show I'm
Ken Coleman joined by my colleague Dr
John deloney the phone number to jump in
on the conversation about your life
specifically your money relationships
and work is triple eight eight two five
five two two five our scripture of the
day comes from Psalm 90 verse 12 so
teach us to number our days that we may
get a heart of wisdom
and then our quote from Frank Sinatra
as smooth as he was
this may be his greatest contribution
I'm going to live till I die and he
dropped the mic
was Frank drunk when he said that
or was he just feeling uh like he was
just being wise philosophic yeah I'm
gonna live until I die then you add more
to that pretty strong stuff I love
pretty wise yes it is all right let's go
to New York City the Big Apple where
Brian awaits Brian how can we help
hello Brian
Hi how are you thanks for taking my call
you bet what's going on
um so I'm looking to purchase a used car
we follow the plan we saved up all our
money but every dealership we go to uh
is willing to give us more or less 500
to a thousand dollars off if we were to
finance instead of paying up front
because they make more money they have
an incentive to finance the cars from
their dealership
they are trying to make themselves more
money they are not your friends
so would you say forego that thousand
dollar discounts
I can tell you what I just bought a new
car a few months ago and I said I'm not
doing that and this is what I'm gonna
pay for this car and I actually ended up
punting out probably two or three extra
months and
um a really remarkable guy
um from the dealership ended up calling
me back and we shook hands
oh that uh yeah that's so much better we
were thinking of putting maybe like 95
down and then maybe trying to just pay
it off all at once to get that discount
maybe I I I I understand that
mathematically it makes sense to me to
say like well fine I'll take the
thousand bucks I'll go through all the
rigmaru
um
I don't I I don't want to participate in
the game and so if somebody says hey
I'll give you a thousand dollars off
then that's telling me you can
so cool that's the new price you just
set it I'll write you a check right in a
second and I'll hand you a check and if
you don't want my check I'll walk out
the door
oh okay I appreciate it yeah and all I
can tell you is that's how I'll do it in
my house like you know I'm sure someone
can sit down and map out the math better
than that I'm just not gonna play that
game man
yeah I I agree and would you have
reservations with purchasing something
second hand I'm not a car guy obviously
I could save a lot of money I have the
cash what do you mean by second hand
uh rather a a private sale I do it all I
gotta tell you I've done it all the time
yeah you know but let's let's do this
ask them if they'd be willing unless you
take it to your mechanic figure it out
yeah you know and if they aren't and if
they feel Shady when you look them in
the eye and you're asking basic
questions and you know if it's too good
to be true it's from my experience it's
true certainly when it comes to used
cars but
um man I'm gonna tell you something I
I'd be all over Facebook Marketplace
Craigslist whatever I mean uh private
selling right now I mean people are are
much more willing to to negotiate and if
you show up with cash I'll never forget
first time I bought
a car from someone else I was probably
in my late 20s you know and I was just
looking for something to upgrade and uh
and I I walked up to the guy I liked the
car I looked at it I think it was an
Infiniti J30 it was silver and it was
pretty cool little car back then and I
and I and I he was asking I think 7 500
for it or something
and uh I walked in with sixty five
hundred dollars I mean to this guy's
house in his driveway I looked at it I
liked it and I literally pulled out
sixty five hundred dollars
in cash and put it on the hood it wasn't
dramatic I just went this is what I can
offer you I can't offer you any more
this is all 6 500 in cash and he went
well young man I believe you got
yourself a deal right and I just think
that's more likely to happen when you're
talking to a real person who doesn't
have margins and a manager and all those
other things so yeah I'd go secondhand
all day long all day we're going to put
a link in the show notes to an article
on how to buy a used car and it'll walk
you through all the steps you can take I
know that many mechanic shops across the
country have a deal you know for 350
bucks or 500 bucks we'll look at your
yeah at a used car or 150 bucks whatever
it may be we'll look at your used car
we'll do our 128 point inspection we'll
run through it and and we'll just look
take a take a quick look at it but I I
think I would have I would do that with
any one of my used cars but I mean I
wouldn't think twice about secondhand uh
purchases and Brian you know it's not
the best deal you called us to get our
take there you go but trust your gut you
were right let's go to David now in
Santa Monica California oh I love me
some Santa Monica Pier I could smell the
food right now John let's go David how
can we help
hi thank you guys first of all for
taking my call my girlfriend has high
expectations uh for a house uh how do I
afford it
think you can afford it you know you
can't afford her expectation
the well that's uh but how do I I mean
she earns a decent uh living and we're
kind of thinking about whether you know
it's time for us to for me to maybe
propose and you know but I want to set
this out right before
David and that's why I want you guys
advice all right I'm gonna be like no
here's my advice advice number one is
um and there there's a moral aspect to
this let's put that aside
the business-wise mathematically don't
buy a house with somebody until you're
married there are legal protections to
home ownership that don't apply when you
are just dating somebody
okay if you are married and you'll get a
divorce and you sell the house there is
a a legal structure for how that that
separation works if you are just dating
then you're talking forensic account
you're talking a mess I didn't pay that
you paid the rent I paid the oh my gosh
so that's step number one Let's Pretend
y'all got married you'll go down the JP
next week and you'll get married and now
you're gonna buy a house
okay there's a simple set of steps you
can have the highest taste in the world
the greatest standards in the world that
is awesome I love all that if you can't
afford it you can't afford it
this is this isn't a matter of taste
this is a matter of math and uh
unrealistic expectations
I can't afford I'm not even talking
about what your guys's ratio is I'm
talking about right what then you can't
afford so David David listen so so you
have to tell her this because if if you
were to somehow try to make this work
those unrealistic expectations that
she's got right now and you start
working through this and you go I'm
already there there's no way
then she needs to know that her
expectations are unrealistic and thus
she's gonna deal with unmet expectations
then we're going to find out if she
wants a ring and what you're this is the
reality relationally for you guys right
yeah you are going to be Trading
a house that you can't afford
for anxiety yep extra depression yeah
you're gonna choose to die young but I
want to get give her a number
because she's she's gonna come back at
me and say oh okay so if we can't afford
this number what what number continue
what can we put 10 to 20 cash down and
what is not more than 25 percent of our
take-home salary every month there you
go as a mortgage payment period
I bought a house two and a half years
ago that's the same ratio I used Ken
bought a house that's the same rate
that's that's no no no no no but what
what her come back to me will be is
listen you bought your condo
uh when you couldn't well and
technically I couldn't afford it but
back uh what I was earning back then
which was 12 15 years ago but now
because I bought in a great neighborhood
and I have
quite a bit uh of equity in it
that's uh when you get married sell your
content hey why don't you use this same
rationale well number one you could say
I was young and dumb and if we want to
go back 15 years I was an idiot
yeah but I want to know if does this
woman want you yeah or does she want a
house y'all don't need to get married
right now I I gotta tell you man I I
don't know John I don't have a good
feeling about this because your
comebacks are all based on you agree
with us but all you're telling us is
what she's gonna say yeah but my friend
what do you you agree with this because
you believe it so forget what John and I
think you believe it and yet all you're
worried about is her comeback and I
think you guys are miles apart her
comeback is a kid in a in a sandbox
like I've taken my ball and going home
yeah we all did stupid stuff 15 years
ago thank God we survived him I'm not
doing it again
I love you and
you and sure and I love our relationship
and I love our future marriage more than
I do trying to get the the bathrooms to
look just right I'm not gonna live that
life no house no ring yet David all
right John deloney great hour I want to
thank the team for keeping us on the air
and you America for listening this is
the Ramsey Show
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world to get
your daily dose of advice on life and
money check out all of our shows from
the Ramsay Network wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]